welcome to this video I'm playing full
step and feed a master from the US
pretty low rating for freedom awesome
but some own yeah Matt its own it so
blitz some some people simply don't earn
don't have the speed on the mouse
handling to to have good results okay um
i'ma playing against the stone wall with
Quincy to I guess the sum if i'm not
mistaken was a recommendation of Boris a
Brooks and his son d for repertoire book
I never really looked at this in much
detail but it's an interesting way to
play somehow it seems a bit bit off here
not quite sure Queen only seven or
something missing up I don't know okay
but anyway it's um it's not a bad setup
I also still have the ideas of Bishop f4
okay I think it gets some idea why he's
writing his solo this very normal
position he spends lots of time but okay
it's like throwing stones in a glass
house as we would then have had
translated German figure of speech 1 2 1
i'm also always able to spend lots of
time for no particular reason okay so i
was playing for before and he prevented
that for a moment with a 5 and a 3
reinforces the before idea in fact if
i'm not mistaken if he plays Queenie 7i
can play before
way this is one of the ideas of the set
up because of a trick with 94 m Bishop
g5 I can show that later so maybe a bit
difficult to explain without putting it
on the board okay let's play before this
was the idea anyway not think too long
use the time time advantage for once but
not thinking ages myself okay Knight to
d7 yeah this invites be fired really
attacking the pawn chain this stone wall
structure would be six it it's very
vulnerable to this before b5 the ideas
and 97 played right into that okay now i
need to recapture if it takes be 5 i'm
going to take d5 and his structures is a
real mess okay now this is so this even
playable I take d5 and 295 something
like that all night g5 immediately or
does he playing on 95 he's 6 is hanging
and d fibers hanging
Knight f6 m-maybe Knight f6 okay if I
take here I've taken d5 got many ideas I
could I could take on c5 n t5 and then
then play night my GF amazon i def 6mm
hmm I'm not sure that this this doesn't
did this feels like it should should be
should be m there should be some
reputation because it's very shaking out
all this like I went I go for that now
but then I'm absolutely unsure if this
was really the best taking d5 we can
take d4 I take d 5 with check so um
cannot really take him I believe oh ok
they did to take that yeah I thought I
just take you 5 mm that's um I could
also wait wait wait i could also give
queen bee three maybe this is even
stronger
I could also take here lots of lots of
choices yam decision should also be good
you just Queen d5 Queenie 8mm add plant
will be three actually but that might
not take
got you find the Sun just impossible to
defend check that don't really think
there's any compensation now I'm very
quickly with Bishop e3 route d1 his son
is it pentium
now that's no compensation at all it's
just an exchange
yeah he needs to move it of the of the
fr thank you Jeff seven or something
every rule of quadruped c1 pinning the
bishop ok this was also also possible
let the beep or now let's let's run the
beep on
yeah and then be born decides probably
look d one arm or does the easiest Tim I
can also just take on c5 would be seven
points always protected by the bishop I
never just give it back on c5 then look
a like a grade one takes on time now I
think c5 all this was a bit mistimed
around here after be five white should
have some some edge the computer doesn't
really think black is so bad yeah mmm
interesting okay but it gives wider
cleared Shem ok this is this is some
good because it is identical to my my
assessment it says Knight f6 some of the
best defense interesting I mean not not
f6 I easily believe that the best
defense but it gives this as an
interesting continuation yeah this is
not not uncommon using this this pin in
the stone wall but this is actually very
strong the the bishop cannot really
retreat let's say it goes to e7 there's
immediate b6 this looks ugly for black I
cannot this is this is even worse so I'm
probably something like that and then I
don't know Bishop e3 Bishop f4 no yeah
why does some white is a bit better here
but black is still still in the game
it's not nearly loss or something
this however is an immediate loss yeah
it's minus 4 yeah it's it's not possible
to protect all this if you look at this
just a song a very very easy win alright
thanks for watching